حتى الان وهذه عطاي على البحر الابيض
المتوسط يسكنها غالبيه من الاتراك التي
تعود اصولهم للعربيه ويتحدثون حتى العربيه
في كثير من الاحيان واغلب الذين يعملون
فيه دول الخليج ربما ينتمون الى هاتاي
وتضررت كثيرا بالزلزال نسبتها 53
و38 لاردوغان كالجدار اوغل 42 و 39
ونسبه هنا منخفضه جدا 3.89 ربما مفهوم لان
اوغان قومي وهؤلاء تعود اصولهم كثير منهم
اصولهم عربيه فبالتالي يمكن يفهم لماذا
وضع سنان اوغن في هذه الولايه تحديدا اقل
من الولايات الاخرى اذا الرئيس التركي
بنسبه نوعا ما مريحه وانا قمت قد ذكرت
انها لم تكن مريحه جدا في الانتخابات
السابقه ليست مثلا مثل اديمان او غازي
عنتاب او شانلي اورفا او
كيليس لا هاتاي متذبذبه في كثير من
الاحيان وهناك معارضه قويه فيها لكن مع
ذلك حتى الان رغم ما حصل محيي تقريبا
انطاكيا في الزلزال ومع ذلك الاصوات 53
تعتبر جيده بالنسبه للاردغان نظرا للفارق
مع كل جدار اوغلو يعني يقترب من تسعه
بالمئه وهي حتى الان مريحه بالنسبه للرئيس
التركي في هاتاي